[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is Caleb
Denby and I will be your driver on this
journey tonight on the road I wanted to
continue the clutch chest
pipe and take a look at one of the more
fun more interesting quarterfinal
matches from clutch chess this match of
course was the one between the world
champion Magnus Carlsen and the
up-and-coming the United States prodigy
Jeffrey Zhang
so Jeffrey of course with the tough
pairing in the first round I believe
they had him seated as eighth of eight
in the tournament which is why he faced
off against the world number one right
away but it really shaped up to be a
much more interesting match and I think
a lot of people expected with Jeffrey
even taking a couple wins off of the
world champion so I wanted to dive into
some of those games here today because
there are a lot of fun and I think
there's always something to be learned
from these top-level games so starting
off we have a game between Magnus and
Jeffrey I wanted to start with this one
because I like it
so Magnus played the move see for
Jeffrey it plays the move c5 we have
asymmetrical English it follows up
Knight c3 g6 and now III by the world
champion is not quite the normal move
here generally the symmetrical English
stays symmetrical for a while longer
moves like g3 and the bishops getting
fianchettoed black also bringing the
night out and you see how the symmetry
kind of pervades for a while but Magnus
having none of that plays in early III
now Bishop g7 by Jeffrey was actually
not his choice that's the most common
move Knight of 6 is also perfectly
reasonable it'll transpose quite shortly
we had d4 by Magnus C takes d4 he takes
d4 and then those that are fans of the
Greenfeld defense will likely recognize
some of these types of positions
Geoffrey followed this up with
d 5 this was his points of playing the
early night of six and now we are in
fact just in some pretty standard Grune
Feld stuff in fact I think this might be
more of an anti Grune felt with III
played in response to c5 you can also
get here believe it or not from the
caro-kann with c6 and d5 and the en see
pawns being traded as such so this
position pretty common throughout chess
you can get here a variety of ways
Magnus just arriving via the English
attack or English opening now Queen b3
is Magnus Carlsen space and this is the
point of his opening play so far
he plays Queen b3 in order to pressure
this d5 pawn now in a lot of green felts
you see white just captured this right
away well I can go ahead and recapture
and then from here you know a trade on
c3 might occur and a lot of the main
lines but these are slightly different
and white tries to prove his advantage
not by having an overwhelming center
right away but rather trying to prove
that this pawn is a little bit too weak
where it's that now it's tempting to try
to solve this problem immediately by
just capturing here but that's gonna run
into bishop takes c4 when all of a
sudden you're facing a rather
uncomfortable battery towards your Kings
side and it move like e6000 it not on
the cards which is why Geoffrey it
simply plays the move Bishop g7 and this
is more or less the standard way of
dealing with this opening by white you
just allow black you allow white to
capture on d5 we're not so worried about
temporarily losing this pawn it is on a
half-open file in front of our queen we
can easily maneuver our pieces to attack
this pawn some more and so Geoffrey
isn't concerned about this pawn
temporarily coming under fire black went
ahead and castled now why continued with
Bishop e2 and now black plays this move
Knight a6
by Jeffrey this is just a roundabout way
I'm aiming for the c7 square to get at
this pawn the movement Knight B to d7 is
also totally playable it's pretty
natural and play might continue there
with this Knight coming to b6 but we'll
see that Jeffrey actually has a really
interesting move in mind here after the
move Knight a6 so 96 Bishop f3 I'm gonna
ask you guys to try and find Geoffrey's
move here it's not a total novelty but
it's definitely a very very off-beat
move offbeat approach to this opening so
let me give you some something to go off
of here white is totally defending this
pawn with everything he's got so far and
so while you can just play move like
nine c7 immediately you're not going to
actually get very far why it's just
gonna continue development and you've
made no progress towards getting rid of
this deep on so try to find some really
active way to take off some of these
defenders and get after this D pawn as
quickly as possible see what you guys
come up with go ahead take a second at
home see what you got
well yeah the Greenfeld without the epon
like I said you hear from some of these
anti Grund felts where white doesn't
play well place a little bit differently
with III rather than a 44 can you say
the answer if you've seen the game sure
why why not we'll get there so the move
Bishop g4 isn't a bad move either it's
not the most common here I don't think
this has been tried it does succeed in
removing a defender of the d5 pawn the
issue is you just spend a little bit too
much time doing it because you remove a
defender you also remove your attacker
temporarily and now White's just gonna
develop nicely you really have nothing
better than coming straight back to f6
and you're just starting to spend a bit
too much time with this removal so
Bishop g4 not quite the idea here some
people in the chat have it one
self-confessed had already seen the game
the movie six is also not really what
we're looking for
unfortunately this pawn was captured for
free so we're not so interested in
giving it up in exchange for another
pawn because that still does leave us
down upon me you want to win this guy
for free so Geoffrey's crazy idea here
is in fact this move that you guys came
up with b5 and this is a really nice
idea by white the point is while this
pawn is attacked twice and defended zero
times there's actually no convenient way
for white to capture here if white takes
back with the Knights well what's going
to happen is the move rook b8 are all of
a sudden you are very much pinned to the
Queen here and there's no real way to
solve this issue if you play a four
that's a good start but now the move
Knight c7 comes on the board and no good
way to protect this Knight a six is
going to be coming next and black will
have plenty of compensation in
this line if you take with the Queen on
the other hand well now this is a little
bit less clear but rook b8 will still
come on the board the Queen can come
back to a four and now what's the
follow-up here for black does anybody
see the point of the sacrifice in in
this line this is something that you
absolutely need to to figure out here
yeah I don't think b7 is too important
in the Bishop g4 line for many of the
same reasons that we see here if you
play Queen takes b7 well let's see I
think eventually we'll just play Queen I
5 bring your work to the B file and have
some compensation but that's probably
another reason to not go for that
anyways b5 Queen b5 what is the point
here so yeah Beltran has it in the chat
the point is not actually to play rook
before when Queen D 1 would be
comfortably defending for white but
rather we do want to bring this night to
be four and all of a sudden these two
moves become very very serious threats
and Queen D 1 still might seem like a
solution but it's very very temporarily
temporary when you realize there's no
good way to deal with Bishop f5 when
these squares are coming under fire so
night before pretty devastating actually
to White's position if it is allowed so
for these reasons
Magnus did actually shy away from
capturing this pawn immediately instead
he plays the move Knight G e2 just
developing naturally now Geoffrey maybe
missteps a little bit here the idea of
b5 was one yes it's a legitimate
sacrifice if white captures but of
course if white ignores it the point
originally was to help break down the
defense of this deep on so the very a
very logical follow-up to this would be
in fact to play the move b4 now perhaps
Geoffrey was actually concerned about
this move Knight b5 anyways now rook b8
of course would not be a pin here but
this would allow Knight takes a 7 so
rook b8 not going to be a legitimate
move
in this case but we could still just
attack this guy was something like Queen
d7 but maybe Jeffry was worried about
Bishop e7 when all of a sudden the move
d6 is starting to become like a playable
option for white note this Queen does
cover f3 so we don't have to recapture
like this so with these ideas in mind
Geoffrey just started with the move rook
b8 and this is an okay move
but before was just a bit stronger going
for these more forcing lines even if
Knight b5 is legal straight away so
after rook b8 the very very natural move
for white is this move that was played
in the game Bishop f4 you just hit this
rook develop with tempo and now black
simply brings this rook out to be six
now perhaps feeling happy with his
active bishops or Magnus got a little
bit overconfident here maybe and simply
captured on b5 did not see a reason that
this move could be refuted so I want to
ask you guys at home try and find out
what the difference is here as compared
to Knight takes b5 in the first position
that we looked at it what's different
here for white why does Magnus think
he's allowed to take this pawn and once
you think about all those things maybe
you can try and come up with Geoffrey
Zhang's next move which proves the world
champion wrong proves that this pawn
still was not able to be captured so
what is the idea
what was Magnus's point and then what is
Jeffries counterpoint for example
so Suba kura I think has already seen
the game and does have all the answers
here so yeah of course the point in the
original line if we can back up if
Magnus took here the idea was to player
it could be 8 a 4 in Knight c7 and this
was how we were attacking this knight on
b5 so 97 was the key move now in the
position in the game of course Knight c7
is not going to be playable
thanks to this bishop on f4 this is why
Magnus kind of went for this line just
assuming this Bishop on f4 is enough and
it will be regaining the c7 squared not
allowing black to take advantage of it
so Geoffrey comes up with a very direct
very interesting move g5 and this is the
one to show that's Magnus Carlsen was a
little bit off when he took this beep on
now unfortunately g5 has two threats one
it attacks this bishop but number two
it's also threatening to come to g4 when
miraculously this bishop on f3 has
absolutely zero squares to move to so
with this bishop immobile on f3 Magnus
absolutely has to capture on g5 as he
does and now the move Knight c7 comes on
the board hits this Knight and Magnus is
actually helpless now to save his piece
so a4 played in the game a 6 and this
piece is a goner now unfortunately for
Geoffrey he was in fact still playing
the world champion and so the game
continued and well now the story of the
game was really a common story in this
Magnus Carlsen against Jeffries young
match and that is Magnus sometimes in
these games just won outright one very
clearly without no issues just played
better than Geoffrey Geoffrey made a
mistake early on but in a lot of these
games Geoffrey actually managed to pull
off some pretty sneaky tricks as we see
in this game go up very significant
material or very significant positional
edges
and then Magnus still somehow battles
his way back into the game
and so that's what I wanted to kind of
focus on in this game here how Magnus is
battling back after going down the piece
so let's start in this position here
this is you know the kind of moment of
disaster for the world champion I'm sure
we've all had some experience in
positions like these where the
realization has occurred g5 we have to
take now a6 and her Knights hanging so
what do you do how do you want to
approach this position down this
material in order to give Geoffrey the
the most problems what can you do here
to keep the game kind of alive what are
some ideas
anybody anybody in the chat
okay not a ton of ideas so I'll keep
talking a little bit obviously you know
this night's a goner so what you don't
want to do is try and well I guess you
know in in your classflow games you can
try and find tactical ways to get out of
things like this in this case no such
tactic exists this one is a pretty
simple just attack of the night no way
to get out of it so what you need to do
now is find ways to activate your
remaining pieces so you just want to get
the most activity as possible for your
remaining pieces to try and compensate
for the lack of the night that you're
about to face so specifically right now
I'm looking at this piece on f3 and I'm
thinking what can I do to keep this
Bishop active and that's how Magnus
Carlsen likely arrived at the move
played in the game d6 and this is in
fact going to be the best move for
Magnus to keep the game going here you
play d6 now all of a sudden you have
this crazy bishop
I'm bearing down on this open diagonal
and for the moment it is unopposed by
the black pieces black of course does
capture on d6 can't let that pawn stay
there and now white simply castles
getting the King safe but that d6 move
does turn out to be really really
important to this game
Magnus needs this bishop now the move a
takes b5 is played in the game and once
again I want to pause for just a moment
here and ask the chat how you want to
approach this position with white White
has succeeded in sort of activating his
remaining pieces but when you get in a
position like this where you are down
significant material or down a
significant positional disadvantage what
you really need in the game is something
to play for so in some cases you'll see
one of these super strong players go
down material and then we'll just sort
of wildly and crazily try to
attack the king in this case blacks king
is too safe for that idea to work so we
need to find something else to play it
for so that's the question I'm asking to
you guys number one what move do you
play here and number two what are you
playing for in this position how are you
trying to still win or you know equalize
or come back despite being down in this
full piece so go ahead and take a second
try and figure this one out I'm feeling
like my chat might just not be working
something to refresh that so he kept my
chat was in fact not working in the chat
did say d6 I was not just talking myself
and now they do have the correct move
here
a5 and this is what Magnus plays for in
the game he is playing to keep the past
pawn on the a file in tandem with this
very active Bishop on f3 he's gonna try
and push this guy forward for victory
and that's exactly what you need to do
in positions like these everybody kind
of knows the the old adage don't trade
down material don't trade down when
you're down materials so if you're down
a piece down a couple pawns you
generally want to keep pieces on the
board the extension of that is that when
you're down material the reason you want
to keep these pieces on is because you
want to make more complications you
don't want things to be simple because
when things get to be simple that's when
the material edge is just going to show
itself so moves like a f5 moves that
keep like this file closed for the rook
keep your chances of promoting this a
pawn alive or exactly what you need to
be doing in positions like this where
you're in fact down material so a5 great
idea everybody good job on that one
Geoffrey brings the rook all the way
back to b8 I will mention that rook a 6
was perhaps a little bit more accurate
here just immediately pressuring this
pawn but rook b8 isn't a bad move 93 by
the world champion and now 96
by Jeffrey is trying to untangle just a
bit this Bishop dropped back to III and
then Jeffrey in perhaps not his proudest
moment ever is up the peace here
but was feeling a little bit of the
pressure maybe of this pawn on a five a
little bit of pressure of these two
active bishops and he started to repeat
moves
despite definitely having the advantage
in this case so the players repeated
moves for a while Knight c7 and this
move actually does offer Magnus the
threefold repetition Magnus could have
said alright I'm gonna play Bishop g5
and agreed to a draw instead though
Magnus is actually the one that deviates
which shows you his absolute confidence
in positions like these he truly
believes that he can outplay his
opponent despite being down in the full
piece so he plays the move rook F to c1
here now with this deviation Geoffrey is
realizing okay the game is not gonna be
is totally over just yet and so he plays
the move Bishop e6 to keep the game
going develop his pieces Queen d1 now by
Magnus this Queen really had nowhere
better to go if you come out to a square
like before you're actually asking for
quite a lot of trouble with Knight C to
d5 when this active Bishop is going to
die not what you want so the Queen just
comes all the way back to d1 now F d5
still comes on the board and now Magnus
starts pushing this upon even further up
the a file and this is once again what
you need to be doing in positions like
this where you're kind of going for
broke here when in doubt you find
something to play for and then play for
it with kind of everything you've got
and that's what Magnus is doing with
this a pawn so a6 rook a8 pawn goes all
the way up to a 7 and now we have Queen
c7 by black here and this move was
perhaps a little bit off in this case
you know the adage trade pieces when
you're up material don't trade when
you're down material actually holds true
here
and perhaps the best move was Knight
takes III now this is not the best move
necessarily because it trades off the
dark squared bishop but because it does
allow whack to play a really nice move
to follow up so who in the chat room
understands why Knight takes ef3 is the
best what's the nice follow-up here for
black
after okay six maybe Queen D three I'm
now reading sorry my chat room seems to
have some difficulties I mean yeah Queen
D 3 is a fine move there's there's
nothing totally wrong with it but I
guess you're just trying to take this
but it is defended I don't know it's
just a move it's just a position but
okay in this position here that I'm
talking about a 7y is Knight takes III
in the best move so my chat room is
really struggling so yeah the idea is
after takes takes probably not Bishop d5
as you are asking for a little bit of
trouble here the move Knight f5 might
come and we do really like this Bishop
to be controlling some of these squares
on the Kings side but rather pawn to d5
is going to be the idea and with this
Bishop cut off now blacks life becomes a
lot a lot easier without having to worry
about this pin on this long diagonal
instead though we did see Queen e7 and
now Knight h5 by Magnus is still once
again just playing it for more
complications now things like Knight f4
start to become a threat you want to
break down blacks control of this d5
square in the game Geoffrey did capture
on e3 f takes III and now once again
this d5 move was perhaps the idea that
Geoffrey should have gone for here just
blocking down this long diagonal instead
Bishop h6 was his choice which is also a
fine move but I really do like this idea
of just shutting down the opponent's
activity that's how you can really win
these positions without too much you
know controversy you want to make things
simple for yourself yeah so Sarah one of
course has a great acronym that he likes
to pull out on occasion in his lectures
called kiss which stands for keep it
simple stupid and that's really the way
to go so get pieces off the board close
off your opponent's activity get rid of
this a pawn and then it should be smooth
sailing for black of course it's all
easier said than done here
in this case jeffrey is now also giving
back this rook on a8 which was all part
of his plan he includes now this Bishop
takes III idea and after King age 1 he
takes on c1 Queen takes c1 and now rook
takes a so at the end of the day
Geoffrey is actually in fact keeping the
exchange through these tactical means
and so this was good by Geoffrey
unfortunately in the middle of these
tactics after Bishop takes c1 Magnus
actually missed a chance here to more or
less keep his his uh a pawn chances a
little bit more alive keep them a little
bit more threatening here after Bishop
takes C pawn queen takes me one of
course is the natural recapture but
Bishop b7 was actually a really great
move by Magnus here it would have kept
this a pawn alive kept this LightSquared
Bishop alive controlling the queening
square and black might actually be in
for a little bit more trouble than he
reckoned in this type of position but ok
let's not focus on those minutia instead
we do end up with this position
Magnus plays Queen c3 and this is once
again another attempt to keep the game
going keep complications alive so of
course the idea of Queen to c3 is to go
after this King on g8 and I said earlier
on that often when you see these strong
players going down material their go-to
strategy is to go after the king in that
position though the black king was far
too safe in this case it's looking a lot
less sheltered no the Knight has landed
on h5 and more pieces have been traded
off so why the switch now for Magnus
Carlsen from solely focusing on the a
pawn - now focusing on the King well
practically Magnus's opponent Geoffrey
kind of focused all of his forces over
on this a pawn here even this Bishop is
starting to think about coming to d5 to
guard the a8 square so when your
opponent puts all of their pieces in an
attempt to stop your idea that's
generally the right time to start
looking for something on the other side
of the board and this is how Magnus is
able to swindle his way not necessarily
swindle but just play his way out of
these bad positions where he's down
material you make threats on one side of
the board tests your opponent on that
side if they succeed in solving all of
those problems
Magnus switches to the other side and
asks him some more questions over there
and in fact Geoffrey was not up to the
task
in this case and blundered on the next
turn in the game he plays the move
Knight d5 but this in fact is not going
to be good enough for for a win here
turns out Magnus Carlsen did have a
force line here with Queen g3 check King
f8 Queen g7 check King e8 Queen h8 Queen
f8 9 7 King East 7 now after Queen takes
h7 believe it or not this is just going
to be zeroes according to the computer
but practically this does actually look
very good for white in my opinion looks
tough to play for black you have to go
for something like NAT of 6 Queen age 6
Knight back to d5 Queen back to age 7 is
the computers top choice but
realistically this is probably how the
game would end in a draw can't really do
anything with this Queen because you
need to move this Knight out of the way
but you can't move the knight out of the
way until you deal with the pin on the
Queen and that is how you arrive at this
kind of crazy-looking draw of course you
know not all of this is so clear to a
human mind in a rapid game where Magnus
has a minute and 20 seconds on the clock
so Queen c6 instead was played in the
game no Knight back to c7 Queen b7 was
Magnus Carlsen choice and now Geoffrey
has actually achieved a winning position
and I would like you guys at home to try
and find the win here that Geoffrey
missed he does have
move that just absolutely wins the game
on the spot go ahead you guys at home
try and see if you can find it black to
move and win here black to move and win
does anybody have it I also don't
understand this issue with the chat on
my phone it just does not work so yet
you guys do have it it is going to be
Bishop d5 but I mean obviously the line
does not end here I think Magnus's idea
after this move was probably just Queen
b8 check but fortunately black does have
a way out of this and the bishop covers
the rook so we are able to just move
this Knight back to e8 this is actually
the only move if Queen e8 of course
you're missing this Knight but more
importantly you are missing this fork to
the king so 98 must be played now Knight
f6 check gets you nothing cuz the rook
actually defends the night you get this
weird triangle of pieces all defending
each other and there's simply nothing to
be done here for for white you can try
to come back with the knight but Queen
b7 is next on the agenda for black
forcing this Queen out and after the
Queen's come off the board this King is
totally safe and this pawn is going
nowhere with just a rook and a knight
left on the board so this was the win
that Geoffrey missed Bishop d5 instead
he went for Bishop g4 and all of a
sudden the threats to the King and the
threats of the a pawn all culminate in a
win for white now of course the key
difference is Queen B a check for Magnus
and this Bishop is lacking not defending
this rook this of course means that 98
is no longer possible Queen e8 fails to
the same idea and between f8 has played
in the game is not gonna be good enough
after Knight f6 check takes on f8 takes
f8n Knight takes chief war sufficiently
for a very unfortunate miss by Geoffrey
but this is what Magnus kind of was able
to do in every bad position he got in
this match now not to say he got a bad
position every time he had a lot of
great wins from good positions just Out
playing Geoffrey but in the bad
positions that he did get this was not
an uncommon story
Magnus just keeping the game going
keeping complications alive until
Geoffrey unfortunately was not able to
keep up with the same accuracy in time
pressure so Knight takes g4 and this
game is now definitely White's to win
which he does go on to do
kingi 793 King d7 d5 and now this Knight
gets a little bit active Magnus
sacrifices the D pawn brings the rook
out to a6 gets black steep own in
exchange and at the end of the day
Magnus is up a strong H pawn with
actively pace or actively placed pieces
and this endgame is actually just going
to be a pretty basic win here rook takes
g6 a nice idea to cap it off Rick h1 and
now the winning move for Magnus not
immediately capturing this rook allowing
Queens and queens which would still be
winning but the key move here is it's
just rook b6 don't allow the opponent to
Queen now black just resigned the game
could have continued like this but one
extra night is enough to pretty easily
win in this end game here so Geoffrey
just resigns against Magnus so what was
the point of this game the point was to
show you number one Geoffrey's
interesting opening idea and this nice
tactic that he used to win material
against the world champion but then how
the world champion keeps the game going
d6 a nice move to open the bishop and
then this move
a5 really keeping his chances alive here
and noticing how Magnus shifted between
the Queen side and the Kings side to try
and stretch the opponent's pieces a
little bit thin
and that is how he managed to make
Geoffrey blunder and go on to win this
game so any questions about this game
before I move on to Game two here any
questions at all and fear here already
blunder I guess so
I think the you would be hard-pressed to
find someone who disagrees with you that
Magnus right now is a better chess
player than Geoffrey give him a few
years though and you might never know
what's my rating I am around 2200 USCF
much worse than these players but I have
had the benefit of analyzing these games
before doing this lecture okay in the
next game I'm a big Jeffrey Zhang fan so
we're not gonna spend too much more time
looking at these losses so let's take a
look at one of these games where Jeffrey
did actually manage to draw blood this
one between Jeffrey Magnus Jeffrey had
the white pieces here I'm not sure what
round this is but it doesn't really
matter they all kind of blend together
they played so many chess games in these
clutch chess matches so efore by Jeffrey
v59 f3 knight c6 and now d4 and we have
of course the scotch game he takes d4
Knight takes d4 Bishop c5 and now Bishop
III and this is all pretty normal stuff
so far in this position black plays this
interesting move Queen f6 this is the
main line the idea is you are
challenging this Knight directly more
importantly you're also keeping an eye
on this e5 square whereas if you play a
move like Knight f6 well you're kind of
asking for trouble here after the move
Knight takes c6 when there are too many
pieces under fire for black to deal with
so that's why Queen f6 stepping out of
these threats and attacking d4 c3 now is
the move Knight G to e7
of course the f6 square occupied by the
Queen and we are still worried a little
bit about
pushes Bishop b5 kingside castles buy
black and it's this move Bishop b5 sorry
that I have skipped over that isn't the
most common here generally the move
Bishop c4 is the main line of these
Scotch positions but there should be
five is it's just another square it's
not like White's going to go super wrong
in this position it's difficult to be
too much worse with the white pieces in
the scotch game even if you play one or
two
funny-looking moves so kingside castles
for black Kings side castles before
white and now Bishop b6 is Magnus's move
and this is the type of move that is
really good for time controls like these
there's of course this other sitting in
chests loose pieces drop off and you see
quite often these top players follow
principals like these just because
fellow principals like these in faster
time control games somehow in slower
time control games that's when you see
them starting to break principles and
the reason for that is in those slower
time control games they have the time to
think out and understand that when
something is truly an exception to the
rule an exception to these principles
whereas in these faster time control
games that's when you see them sometimes
fall more back on solid play stuff like
this should be six of course they still
sometimes go crazy and break all the
principles but having a solid pieces is
a huge huge advantage in faster time
controls because when all your pieces
are defended it's a lot more difficult
to hang them to tactics and moves like
Bishop e6 still follow this idea note
also that moves like a four with
suddenly threatened to trap the bishop
more or less or force it to a square it
doesn't want to go to so that's why we
do see Bishop e6 a4 comes on the board
anyways and now black simply continues
with the move Queen to g6 here and the
idea of course you challenge this pawn
on e4 you also i some squares on the
Kings side
Bishop back to d3 now for Jeffrey just
simple defending this pawn putting the
bishop opposite the Queen now Bishop
takes d4 C takes d4 and night before is
the nice idea by black here
note that fish if takes d4 is is a
pretty substantial decision here and
Magnus would not have played this move
if not for the follow up of night b4
this is kind of the point of blacks play
so Bishop takes d4 is actually a pretty
massive concession number one you give
away the dark squared bishop you give
your opponent the bishop pair this is
the advantage that is negated by - its
next movement night before getting the
bishop pair back but number two you are
giving your opponent the center and this
is going to be the key to slice of
advantage for Jeffrey Zhang in this game
and so looking back I kind of start to
question Magnus's opening choices here
whenever you give your opponent these
two central pawns like this it is of the
utmost importance that these pawns are
not allowed to stand uncontested and in
the game you'll see that Magnus does
somewhat contest these pawns but it just
turns out to not be enough because black
is not ready to deal with the abundance
of space that's white Gate white gets in
the position so night before white
simply develops of course can't move the
bishop out of the third of capture
otherwise the e4 pawn would hang so
Knight c3
we do see Knight takes D three Queen
takes D three and now I'm gonna ask you
to find what I consider to be an only
move for Magnus Carlsen right now so
black to move what is the only kind of
reasonable move that you can come up
with here black to move
so yeah that move of course is going to
be d5 and the reason its d5 is the
reason I was just saying whenever you
give your opponent the center like this
and absolutely must be contested as
quickly as possible that's why I move
like d6 or b6 simply isn't going to be
good enough d6 sure you're developing
the bishop out along the open diagonal
b6 same idea but you're not contesting
in this Center and the longer this
center stays uncontested the more white
can just kind of consolidate and be
ready to meet any advances by black and
just continue pressing in the center so
d5 played in the game of course Jeffrey
wants to keep this strong Center so he
plays the move f3 to support it and I
think honestly this is just going to be
a very very pleasant position for white
from here on out so this is something
that I really want you guys to try to
avoid in your own games of course there
are these modern and hyper modern
systems where you do give your opponent
a large Center with the idea of later
breaking it down but specifically in
this structure where the C pawn has been
treated for the e pawn by black this is
just not going to be a good structure
for black it really isn't
with this full center for white and
we'll see that as we continue later on
into this game so c6 now was played by
the world champion defending the d5
square Queen d2 now by white Bishop e6
so Queen d2 of course stepping out of
any pins along this diagonal and now
white just brings pieces to the center
rook a to e1 Ric 8 e8 by black 92 by
whites now f6 was black's choice and I
think this is another move that was kind
of forced if you don't play f6 for
example you just pass you are really
asking for trouble
with the move e5 followed by
followed by a later f4 probably even a
g4 h 3 f4 f5 and this is how you can
kind of just start to get totally run
over in chess games if you allow stuff
like this to happen
with these strong central pawns that's
when you are really asking for danger so
instead of a six we do have f6 with the
idea preventing this push to e5 by white
and so now is going to be a really key
moment in the game so I want you guys to
pause here take a few seconds to really
think about it maybe even a few minutes
if you're watching just the video take a
few minutes try and work out what you
want to do with the white pieces here
because this is a pretty critical
position you know intuitively you have
this strong Center and you should be
somewhat better but the question still
remains
you know what plan can you achieve here
how do you make use of this Center so go
ahead take a little bit really think
about it and look at your various
options okay I'm gonna introduce a few
candidate moves a few candidate moves to
you here one there is this idea of
Knight f4 to consider with the idea of
taking on e6 there's the idea of
expanding further on the kingside with a
later age for maybe even g4 you could
try and play something like this there's
the idea of just switching to the Queen
side and playing for some kind of
minority attack there's the idea of
trading in the center and there's the
idea of pushing in the center still with
the move e5 alternatively you know
there's a ton of legitimate moves that
you could play here but the important
thing is you do them with a plan so what
do you guys think why didn't he take D
takes e4 last turn good question and the
point is that this Knight f4 move would
be good enough to maintain the extra or
maintain the pawn and
now with two uncontested pawns in the
center this is unstoppable Queen f5 not
quite going to get the job done and so
we can take here anyways and after takes
the move d5 is actually somewhat of a
problem Bishop takes a seven or simply
Bishop f2 things are getting quite nasty
for you quite quickly if you snag this
pawn pretty pretty nasty stuff this
Queen just not going to find any safe
squares in this chess board so okay good
question though good question
instead f6 and now what do you guys want
to do so a lot of people are saying in
the chat Knight f4 with takes on e6 okay
and yeah this is this is fine but the
problem is this is not really a plant
let's say Knight f4 Queen f7 and Knight
takes c6 Queen takes c6 now you're gonna
be left with the exact same questions of
what are you doing in this game so the
same questions still apply here sooo
bucura proposes e5 so why do you want to
play e5 what's your plan after E 5 same
question as the people who say Knight f4
so a.m. says minority attack something
like a b4 here so you have all these
plans floating around right and it looks
like the YouTube chat is actually a
little bit conflicted on on what they
want to do here so positions like these
I really do think the correct way to
think about them is the first planning
and then calculating specifically how
those plans are going to go now that's a
pretty general way of thinking about
chess positions but let's say we do go
for this idea of Queen B 4 and you want
to go Bishop f4 someone in the YouTube
chat said to control the dark squares
this is probably an OK way of playing
but specifically let's just say your
opponent gives you everything you want
they just play b6 to defend this pawn
you go Bishop f4 and now what what what
are you actually doing right you've
controlled some dark squares but but
what are you attaining here let's say
even Knight c8 just to defend some of
these dark squares I'm not saying and
playing this particularly well for black
black could maybe be doing more
interesting things like taking on e4 in
some positions but let's say just Knight
c8 you're controlling some dark squares
but you know in in the future black is
going to try and activate some of these
pieces at some point so the move that
was played in the game I think is
actually the correct move here you could
argue that these ideas of playing on the
Queen side are actually pretty relevant
and well worth considering but I do like
Geoffrey's approach here and the reason
for that is it does grant white the
clearest plan in the move that he played
in the game is the move e5 so what do I
mean when I say that this gives white
the clearest plan well for one it's a
very kind of combative move it's saying
if you don't do anything well now hold
on I am going to start to kind of run
over you on this Queen side with a move
like f4 and threats of expanding even
further to follow so it's a very very
combative move it's really posing a
question to the opponent and because of
that black did in fact capture on e5
which you can debate whether or not was
the best idea by Magnus Carlsen but if
you really leave this pawn standing on
e5 it does optically and intuitively
really look bad for black just that
strong of a center is something that
can't be allowed to stand forever so you
can kind of anticipate F takes e5 or at
least I would anticipate F takes e5 as
was played in the game and so then after
D takes e5 we do automatically see
another threat on the board so we can
calculate this far in our heads
now how is black going to deal with this
threat well the most natural seems to
play seems to be playing v6 so you can
calculate this far in your head this is
what you know is going to happen after
you play the move e5 and so then you
take a look at this position you say
well what am i doing well a clear pant
plan sort of presents itself to you
right you now have a d4 square for your
knight
you now have a half-open C file for your
rooks you have a strong pawn here on e5
that can be defended with the move like
f4 if need be and you still have
pressure along these dark squares right
so how do these all combine well if you
don't allow your opponent to play c5 you
play the move b4 as done in the game you
can transfer all your pieces over to
this side of the board and really
pressure in this Queen side in the
meantime you also have this sort of
fluid epon on e5 it's technically a
passed pawn and that your opponent is
definitely going to have to keep an eye
on as well what's more is suddenly it
becomes very very difficult to propose
an active plan for black any ideas of
opening the D file are now totally gone
any ideas of undermining the e5 pawn
with a move like c5 are now totally gone
and so what's left for black is yes you
can try to play c5 and d4 but obviously
this is going to be very very difficult
with the white pieces aimed at this
square and at this pawn so that is why I
really like the way Geoffrey Zhang
approached this position with the move
e5 and that is how you can kind of
arrive at these ideas yourself in your
own games now obviously this takes this
particular position takes a ton of deep
chest understanding that Geoffrey's
wrong obviously has and it can be tough
to kind of get that understanding but
this is why analyzing your games after
you play them is hugely important
because there are going to be
huge crossroad moments as this like this
position in your own games I think quite
often they kind of appear and so this is
the type of position that you really
want to look at afterwards you want to
say okay so I went through this in the
game because I thought this but what
happens if I would have done this other
thing and this is really where you want
to you know look at your various plants
look at your various options and see
which ones you like so long story short
I like to move v5 because it grants
white a clear plan so look for moves
that give you a clear plan in your games
that's the idea okay II 5 fe 5 de 5 b6
and B for all played in the game rook to
c8 now by black like I said really
difficult to propose any kind of active
plan now for black over on the Kings
side of the board whereas whites
very active plan of attacking me c6
weakness also hinting at expanding on
the Kings side so okay rook c8 the
obvious move by white is rook c1 the
story is now about this C pawn rook FD 8
is trying to support the center even
further and now we do see the killer 94
land on the board and this is clear edge
to white now he played the simple moves
following me 5 to continue with the plan
continue activating his pieces and
because of that he has a very very good
position ok h6 played in the game and
now I'll ask you guys to try and find
Geoffrey Zhang's next move it is an
immediate way to activate this bishop
this is kind of the last piece for
Geoffrey that he is looking to get
slightly more active here so wait to
move and activate this bishop what do
you guys think
Bishop f2 is proposed by su bukhara who
thus far has added like all the right
answers bishop f2 is is a great move
it's it's not a bad move at all that's
not the idea that gephart shows in the
game though actually the idea he shows
in the game is actually this move a5
which I'm a pretty big fan of and the
idea of course is that this Bishop is
fine on e3 it's pressuring this Queen
side but with the move a5 we are
actually creating a direct threat to
these pawns whenever our Knight moves
out of the way of the bishop so I really
like a 5 it's a great way to undermine
this a7 b6 structure and it's what
Geoffrey chose in the game rook d7 by
Magnus is going for just a little more
fluidity with the rooks options to
double in the C file if needed or defend
any of these squares if necessary rather
than take immediately Geoffrey just
plays the mover F to e 1r it could be
seven came on the board
now perhaps Magnus is hinting and
opening up this rook on the B file so a
takes B 6 a takes B 6 and this is like I
said just a very very pleasant position
now for Geoffrey pieces on very very
good squares pressure on c6 and long
term ideas of pushing on the Kings side
Queen e2 was his choice in the game
Magnus broca's other work back to p8 and
like I said the other big advantage is
it's difficult to find an active plan
for black Bishop f2 now was Geoffrey's
choice just tucking this guy back away
attacking in this guy here and after
Bishop h3 this was sort of asking
Geoffrey what are you doing with this
Bishop on f2 you needed to defend this
Square and unfortunately for Geoffrey he
did kind of go astray here just for a
turn obviously we know blacks only idea
in the position yes he can make someone
move threats like Bishop h3 but more or
less the only real idea for black is to
push through with c5 so White's number
one priority is making
sure that c5 is never a good move
unfortunately Jeffry in the game chose
Bishop g3 and with this Bishop leaving
the C five squares defense c5 now
actually does become a playable move for
Magnus and just like that
he is kind of back in the game with the
fight as he does have his own active
play thus the better move was actually
the slightly counterintuitive Queen f1
just to defend this guy you can follow
up with King h1 making sure this Bishop
never lands on h3 again and now if c5
well you are really much very much going
to cause fall into some problems with
some dual threats of Knight f4 attacking
all your pieces and Bishop c5 winning
winning this pawn so that is why this
bishop should have stayed on f2 instead
Bishop g3 okay see Aakash in the chat is
now referencing some internet memes
which I'm just you know catching up with
I went on a week-long vacation next
thing you know you don't know any of the
twitch s lingo it just moves on so fast
and I just I'm still I'm still catching
up so forgive me
so Bishop g3 Magnus correctly comes up
with the move c5 but c5 still is not
without its downsides in this case it
gives up a very very key square on b5
which Geoffrey is able to occupy now
Bishop e6 and the reason b5 was so key
is that now the d6 square does go to
Geoffrey and so still a pleasant
position here the problem is much of the
advantage has actually been lost because
Geoffrey did allow Magnus to break
through a c5 before c5 came on the board
Magnus was playing for really nothing
honestly it was c5 or bust and now c5 on
the board Magnus suddenly does have play
with these two pawns in the game though
this Turkish attacked we saw rook c6 in
the game Geoffrey brings this queen out
to be five and very active square and
you can see that blacks pieces are
definitely not totally happy
just yet rook a8 was Magnus's choice in
the game and this is actually going to
be the beginning of the end
rikiei it was of course an attempt to
solve the issue of b takes e5 when
there's an uncomfortable pin on this
rook but really the move c4 was the only
way to truly solve this this problem on
c5 to keep the material balanced instead
in the game
rook a8 and now b takes e5 was played
rook a fi was played and queen back to
b4 and from here unfortunately the
tactics do work out for Geoffrey
unfortunately for Magnus of course in
the game rook takes e5 was played rook
takes e5 now B takes c5 and after Queen
b7 Geoffrey Zhang is just totally
crushing with this Queen invading on the
Queen side c4 played in the game but
this just gives up in this night on e7
and now Geoffrey is going to win this
game up perhaps a little bit of a
cleaner piece and then in that first
game that we that we looked at so
hopefully you guys enjoyed these two
games from the Magnus Carlsen Geoffrey's
young match I thought I might get to a
few more but turns out I guess we had a
lot to talk about in just those first
two games so once again my name is Caleb
Denby thank you so much for joining me
in this week on the road to 2000 if
you're watching live be sure to stay
tuned for the endgame class that's about
to come right after this one we're gonna
be talking a little bit about rook pawns
should be an exciting one if you're
watching the video that's all for today
thank you so much and I will see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you